I remember seeing Oprah had oprah.com
and I thought how cool would be to have
your name.com now I sought this kid out
so I went to brendan.com and this guy he
had his resume up there and that's all
he had was a resume so I emailed the guy
and I'm like hey man I really love to
own this website could I buy it from you
he goes no it's my name and he says uh
no you know I got my mom she's got
emails associated with the domain all
the stuff I said oh man all right so I
set it my calendar every six months for
six years my calendar would go off and
I'd email him again email it took six
years and my sixth year he said you know
what yeah you know I'd be interested in
that conversation sold it so I got
brandon.com I'm really happy about that
really stupid story but I was like yes
determination most people don't get what
they want because you don't follow
through enough you just don't follow
through it's based out of insecurity you
start and stop start and stop you're
afraid of hurting people's feelings
you're afraid of what they're gonna say
about you you're afraid they're gonna
judge you and
we're afraid of having that L on our
personal resume and so we we stop we
stop and try to do something else where
we're seeing more immediate results but
if it's your goal if it's your dream you
have to follow through one of my
favorite stores is with Brendan Bouchard
and I went to speak at his event in
Phoenix and I I knew of him but I didn't
know him at the time it was his business
partner that had me come out to his
event
and hired me to speak there and that's
where I met Brendan for the first time
and he asked me hey what are you working
on what can I help or you know what's
next for you and I said I won't work on
my book and he said I'd love to uh I'd
love to help I'd love to give you some
feedback on your book like I am
definitely down for that
let's connect and uh he's he asked me
what my phone number was and at the time
I didn't have a phone I didn't use a
phone uh number and I said how about
email and he said oh I'm not really good
on email but if that's the only way then
let's do email so we exchanged emails
and uh I didn't I didn't hear from him
so I I followed up and I said hey
Brendan thank you you know great event
um love to talk about
the book like you suggested and didn't
hear back and followed up a couple weeks
later and didn't hear back and followed
up a couple weeks later and then he said
oh man thank you uh I'm super swamped
right now but uh let's see they're due
come out to my place and we'll do a jam
session or I've got this event coming up
maybe you can come be there I said yeah
I'm down for either which one you want
to do and didn't hear back and then
wrote a couple more messages and didn't
hear back and here's what's really
important
in my head every time I sent another
email I I was questioning myself I was
judging myself like oh I don't want to
bother him
um maybe maybe I'm I'm being too
overwhelming maybe maybe he doesn't
actually want me to come out uh maybe
I'm offending him maybe you know I'm not
respecting him maybe I'm asking for too
much you know that's that's the thought
in my head before every email where in
reality
he's he's just a busy guy he had a lot
of stuff going on he had a launch that
was happening that I wasn't even aware
of uh that he was planning behind the
scenes and so he is he was you know not
crazy stressed out but he just has a lot
on his plate that he's dealing with and
it's hard to tell ourselves that it's
easier to default to the insecurity of
maybe you're bothering maybe you're
asking too much maybe you're not worthy
maybe you should move on the event that
he talked about me coming to was coming
up
and I still hadn't heard back whether
whether he wanted me there or not or you
know my book launch was coming up too
and I thought
I'm gonna send one more email
just one more email that's it I'm gonna
send one more email and hopefully
something happens if not then I'm done
and hopefully you know he doesn't think
I'm a loser or whatever
and he wrote back an email and like hey
sorry man again I'm not super great on
email I've just been swamped planning
all these things uh yeah come on out
come out to the event speak at the event
too and that was his big event that was
you know 30 to 50 000 a year Mastermind
to be a part of that then I spoke on
stage that then at the event after I
spoke
I met with him and Dean graziosi
backstage for an hour over lunch and
planned my entire book strategy that
then led to me getting invited to go to
Brendan's house uh a couple days later
and hang with him and Dean and Tom bilio
and Lewis house and Jay Shetty and
Russell Brunson in all sorts of amazing
humans who built giant businesses all of
that happened
because I sent that one more email
because I followed up but I followed up
and I followed up and I followed up and
it wasn't that he hated me or that he
thought I sucked or that I was being
overwhelming or whatever that that I
kept following up just had the
persistence there's a lot of
opportunities there in front of you
right now
that
just are not happening because there's
not enough follow-up there's not enough
persistence and and I and the reasons
why you're not doing it are based in
reality right I mean I could be
overwhelming it's it's possible it's
possible that he thinks that I'm
overwhelming that I'm not given enough
value that I'm being too selfish that
I'm bothering him I mean it's possible
but we default to just assuming that
instead of actually finding out
and we miss out on a lot of upside and
so here's what I found that really helps
one
you schedule it in
you schedule it in every X number of
weeks right so every two weeks I would
send in another email every two weeks
every two weeks every two weeks every
two weeks every two weeks every two
weeks and I never felt like doing it
because every time I saw that in my task
list
I I didn't want to do it like you know
let's give it another let's give it
another few days let's give it another
week you know I never wanted to do it
but because it was in my calendar I did
it
you will never want to do it because
you're afraid right underneath it is
really just fear it's insecurity you'll
never want to do it so you schedule it
in every two weeks or every week or
every month or whatever the thing is
that makes sense for the timeline that
you're on
schedule it in so that you have to do it
so when it came up I knew I had even
though I didn't want to even though my
heart was beaten like
I still went off and I did it second
thing is
lead with the intention before you write
the email before you make the call
before you do the follow-up like what's
the intention is your intention to screw
this person over is your intention to
just suck up their time is your
intention to negotiate a bad deal for
them hopefully not
if you're if you're a subscriber of this
channel uh hopefully it's with its
positivity and hope and belief and and
mutual you know uh benefits and so if
you lead with that intention every time
it's really unlikely that they're going
to
come back in a really negative way
the truth of the matter is they're
probably just really busy
maybe they're doing something
insane in their life maybe they have a
health scare maybe they're in the
hospital maybe their mom's in the
hospital right like you never know
what's going on behind the scenes
and if you leave with intention as
opposed to a copy paste email or just
some kind of spam if you if you leave
with I love this person I want to do
something with them I want to help I I
want to I want to learn like if that's
the positive intention going in your
your call your email your follow-up will
just be a lot better it'll be a lot
better and people will feel it I forget
who it was I want to say it was
ah no I forget who it is I'm thinking
princess dive I don't think it was her I
wanna I don't forget who it was where
she would say before I
send an email
I would always smile
I would think about the person
and I would smile before I I wrote an
email wrote a letter
and it would always change
the the vibe of the letter right like if
you're thinking love kindness smiling
before you make a video before you do a
DM before you do a uh an email right
like if you're thinking that
chances are you'll make them smile
you know like if you're smiling
before you do it you're probably gonna
make them smile
and so just taking that little pause to
reflect on what is my intention here
instead of defaulting to insecurity and
the stress on your side
default into let's lead with positivity
let's smile let's leave with love
you'd be amazed at how many great things
happen
so those two things
one you put in your calendar
until you get a response like if
somebody if somebody says no
okay
at least you got a response
but again it's likely going to be a
loving no because you followed up so
many times and you've always LED with a
positive intention and love and kindness
they might just say I'm just you know
what I can't do this right now or I'm
not interested or or hey sorry I haven't
gotten back to you let's do this
right A lot of times it's just a timing
a lot of times your timing is way off
and it's not your timing it just doesn't
fit into their life or their world right
now but in two weeks it might or in two
months it might or in two years it might
and if you're following up every two
weeks every two weeks every two weeks
every two weeks and you're leading with
love and kindness and with a positive
intent amazing things will happen
you have a great Mission inside you
you have a desire to serve and the help
and to create great things for the
people who you work with
right like that that is at the core of
Who You Are
and that needs to be spread
and at the beginning when people don't
know who you are it's a little harder to
get attention to get on people's radar
but if you are consistently following
through consistently even in the face of
not getting any response you just
consistently because it's on your
calendar you're consistently following
through and you're leading with the
intention of Love kindness positivity
great things will happen
I promise you great things will happen
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
I remember when I was going to start my
business and I I really wanted to be
good at it you know I was trying to
become an author and a speaker and do
these types of videos and do some online
training for people on the topics of
motivation and marketing and you know
some all these people are saying well
Brandon you know you may or may not be
successful with that you're you know
blah blah and I thought weird thing it's
not like there's a trait of successful
people you look across history and
successful people it's not they're not
from a given background they don't come
from a specific economic stature they're
not in a position where you know they're
they're one demographic or another
Democrat I mean it's all over I mean
we've got thousands of collective years
of history people succeed some people do
some people don't and I think it more
comes down to how do we manage our mind
and how do we manage our days and I
think that there's a difference between
successful people and unsuccessful
people in the way they particularly
think about
approaching something new you know I
think unsuccessful people when they have
a big dream and they start thinking
about what's going to be required to
accomplish that dream they get very
limiting in their beliefs about
themselves and what's possible and
specifically they say three types of
things you know the first thing they
often say is well you know I don't know
how to do that
so they stop
they say you know I I don't have those
things
so they stop
or they say I don't know you know I'm
not like those people I'm not like that
and so they stop
but successful people have a different
way they have the same thing everybody
dreams you dream I dream successful
people dream people just starting out
everybody dreams everyone has a vision
everyone if they can just take five
minutes today and think about their
lives we could all come up with ways to
improve our lives and reach another
level of success joy happiness
achievement contribution fulfillment
Soul you know we can all Elevate but the
challenge is that the unsuccessful
people they keep stopping when they
think of what they currently know have
or are
but successful people say well I want to
do that but I don't know how to do that
but instead of stopping they say well
then my job is to go learn that
they take their current limitation
and they put it on their agenda as a job
to do as a thing to figure out a thing
to make happen instead of saying well I
don't have that
they say well then my job is to go build
that or I'm not like that then they say
well then my job is to go become more of
that become that person who could
accomplish those things you know when I
was starting to do online marketing for
the first time and and I don't know if
how much of my story you know but when I
started doing online marketing I was
literally bankrupt and I went from a
place of bankruptcy to the point where I
really committed to becoming successful
at it and in 18 months I made 4.8
million dollars 4.6 collected I mean it
was just a huge leap right in in
indifference from bankrupt to
multi-millionaire span of 18 months but
what made that breakthrough wasn't that
I had new opportunities it wasn't that I
had new technologies it wasn't like wow
there's the internet now those things
were already there it went I went from
this level of thinking to this level of
thinking I used to say well I I don't
know how to build a web page
so I said agenda figure out how to build
a web page and I spent hours and hours
and hours at nights on weekends from my
job figuring out how to do that and I
said well I don't have one of those
lists you know I don't have any
subscribers nobody knows who I am so I
said job go build a list go get
subscriber go add value and content out
of the marketplace and they'll come I
mean just keep putting stuff out there
and I also didn't say oh my gosh well I
have that dream I can't have that
because I'm not like that because I
wasn't a public speaker I didn't know
how to do video I wasn't like well I'm
not one of those video people well I'm
not a public speaker so I said you know
what I have to go learn that art I have
to go become a better speaker a better
Communicator I have to go become more
confident I have to go become a person
capable of doing these things I have to
change myself to get there I can't wait
for circumstances to change so I can
have my dream then our dreams would
never happen we have to get to the point
of maturity in our lives where we say
Okay 2 two things are going to change my
life something new is going to come into
my life and make me lucky and blessed
and maybe I can't count on that forever
and maybe now instead I have to
consciously design my life and say okay
now if I want to change if I want my
dream something new has to come from me
I'm going to become a better person I'm
going to become a person who is more
optimistic who is more confident who is
more driven not because I am that now
but because we can grow
that you can become the type of person
who needs to uh who you need to be to
achieve your ideal life you can start
today living from your highest ideals
your highest sense of self your
strongest sense of self you don't need
permission you don't need a guy like me
to look at the video camera and say you
have now permission but if you've been
waiting for it you have permission it's
like at some point in your life you just
say okay I have permission to become my
best self and by becoming your best self
you start to achieve your best things
you start to contribute better things
you start to become a better human being
you can do that now today so next time
you're thinking about a big dream don't
think about the things that well I don't
know how to do that and stop think I
don't know how so set it up on your
calendar to go learn those things I
don't have that then set it up step by
step to go build that I'm not like that
then set it up step by step to go
develop those skill sets and those
competencies so you can become that and
ultimately you can achieve that dream
it's there it's waiting for you don't
stop now I know you all have big goals
Big Dreams big aspirations just like I
do you've got Ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you'll you'll fall off and
and having new goals without new habits
is kind of like you know having a new
car without wheels you know the habits
are the wheels they're the things that
make you able to achieve the goals so
you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out on a more regular basis and
then it goes away or you say you know
I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like why what happened I I said I was
gonna be nicer it's that you didn't set
up the most important thing you needed
to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments you have to set up
trigger moments to activate your habits
what do I mean by that well let's say
you want to become a better person you
know you want to become more kind more
patient more loving with people now you
can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision in your journal
or set up on a vision board that you
look at once in a while but in
day-to-day life it's not enough you need
things to trigger you to remind you to
be that particular kind of person right
it's almost like if you could have a
little angel speaking in your ear all
day long to tell you what to do and how
to be you'd obviously become better well
that makes sense well let's use that
idea let's use that idea by setting up
alarms on our phones that trigger us to
do the very things we need to do this
can be so basic you're going to laugh
and then also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with this let's I have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day again you could write that down
on a journal I'm going to be more
present and calm you can meditate in the
mornings like today I'm gonna be more
present and calm and you're gonna you
could you could start out with good
intentions but those fall apart without
a trigger moment set up throughout the
day to remind you that so what if you
did this what if you just set up on your
phone three alarms during the day with a
label that said
close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
p.m and again it happens at 8pm
what's gonna happen you always look at
your phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've talked to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I'm
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right at least could be as simple
as let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water put
your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words so what words would you love
to have describe you as a person that
you would be happy if that was how
people described you what would those
words be have those and now set them up
in your life I teach Executives to do
this as well I have them have a door
frame trigger when they walk into their
office in the morning as soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be
so these are Big crazy things a lot of
people think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you uh have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
you have to be all in and it's the
hardest thing to do because if it fails
then you can feel like a failure
um you know I think of this idea of
performance necessity two stories kind
of come to mind one is I was working
with an Olympic gold medal is Sprinter
and we're in the tunnel and we're going
out and he's talking about the
competition and we get out to the blocks
and I said uh he was really worried
about the competition I said well how do
you even gauge like who who who's going
to win you know in in his particular
race people are winning but by you know
one one hundredths of a second tenths of
a second I mean these are really close
Sprints and I said well how how do you
know I said who would you even bet on
and he says you know I would bet on the
guy
who gets down at the blocks
gets himself settled looks at the finish
line then says I gotta do this
for my mom
and I was like oh
that's good his performance necessity in
that is it's necessary for him to win
that race for his mom
I think of you know when I started
my career and I I really decided to go
all in with writing and online training
this is like 2000 probably six uh I'd
gone broke completely bankrupt and
failed I left my corporate job I had
this cushy kind of corporate job as a
consultant good job left it to right and
I didn't know how to make it as a writer
I want to do seminars workshops didn't
know how to do that so I was pretty much
a hot mess ran out of money
um I got nothing to my name nothing kind
of no positive prospects no one's
calling me accept the guys who want the
money
and um
one night I'm writing and the
apartment's so small on the bed I had uh
my bills my vision boards all my
research all my journals like the bed
was basically the desk the extended desk
and my lady comes in Denise and she
walks past me but she sees I'm like
trying to write so it doesn't want to
disturb me she goes
crawls under the covers of the bed
and I'm just typing kind of casually
typing away
and I look over
and
I see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know
because none of us want to see our you
know
our families suffer because we are
not performing sure
and um
I was just like
figure this out
and I'm telling you I wrote more that
night than any night in my entire life
next day I wrote more than ever that
birth life's golden ticket which came a
bestseller and in you know 18 months
later because I was like I'm gonna
figure out this online thing I mean
throughout marketing I'm going to figure
out how to teach I'm gonna how to train
and get paid for it because I've never
really been paid for those things I said
I'm going to figure out this industry
and I'm gonna make it 18 months later
after her
crawling under the bills I made 4.6
million dollars Jesus online
Total Transformation people like how did
you do it I'm like she gave me she was
my necessity I was not going to let my
woman be in that situation
um and she believed in me she supported
me she married me and uh you know but
that was she was my drive
and the second part was I went all in
with my identity I said I am going to be
a great writer
and I am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was
you know as you said in the intro now
we've graduated over 2 million people
have taken our online courses video
series now I don't think it would have
happened if I hadn't had the guts and
maybe
the no other choice right
right to say this is who I'm going to be
and I'm going to build into that
and it is necessary for me to become
that person so let's go you know the
first way you should not compare
yourself to others is in terms of
especially today their fans their Fame
their followership right Their audience
never do that in my industry that's very
very popular to do and it's ruined a lot
of people's lives who don't ever rise up
to serve because they think they're not
popular enough you know it's like you
write your first book and you don't have
as many sales as other people and you
think oh well I don't have the audience
or you go to someone's fan page and you
see oh my gosh look at their
followership look at how many Instagram
followers they have how many Twitter
followers they have and and because you
see them so big you think oh I could
never be that so you don't even begin
and a lot of people do that they say
well I'm not that big so they never
start but as I always say you know what
no matter how small you start start
something that matters begin it if I
began my career looking at my heroes
looking at a Wayne Dyer or a Tony
Robbins or a Marianne Williamson a
Deepak Chopra a Jim Rohn back in the day
or or looking at people like ogmandinos
who'd sold millions of books or or even
the the famous books that you saw
millions and millions and millions of
copies if I gauge myself to that and
thought that was the expectation I would
never begin
so you can't expect to start out with
tons of people some some people say to
me all the time well Brandon it's so
easy for you because you got millions of
people on your email list and you have
millions of people on Facebook and and
tens of Millions on YouTube I say it
doesn't make it any harder for me I
still show up and shoot this video and
the reason I have the followers and the
fans and the audience is because I
showed up and I started when there was
only one dude 10 dudes 100 dudes a
thousand dudes watching us my first
seminar that I ever did we we only had
22 people in the room and now we fill up
seminars nine times a year often from
people from 46 countries around the
world fly in paying thousands of dollars
a ticket and what did I do I started
with 22 people in a room and most of
those people didn't even pay and every
time the the guy walked in with with
water I counted him as one of those 22
you know like I I had no followership it
was never about how big you start it's
that you start and you get big by
staying at it because what people do is
they put out the first video they write
the first book they they dryer the first
thing online and nobody follows nobody
watches and they quit they get
disappointed and where there's
disappointment there was too high of as
an expectation on achievement versus
learning versus process versus beginning
what you want to do is never be
disappointed and the way that you're
never disappointed is you understand
every single step counts every single
step is learning every single step gets
you going but if you have the aspiration
or the the attention that's only focused
on their followership and meeting that
you'll never begin don't compare your
followership to anybody else's instead
just compare your work ethic be there
show up work get it done the second
thing I want you to compare yourself to
is other people's achievements that
means their wealth their sales number
their uh big house their big car their
whatever else you know their fancy
clothes they're whatever they got don't
look at other people's achievements and
what they have because if you do that
it's also you think well I'm not famous
enough and then you think well I'm not
lucky enough bless enough rich enough
whatever your excuse becomes you gotta
be very very very careful of that and I
know you know that but lately have you
been looking at other people's stuff and
feeling demoralized because of that well
I you know they had a silver spoon in
their mouth or they're so lucky those
types of things stop us from even trying
because we feel like the game is unfair
well it's not most wealthy people
especially all the billionaires I've met
I've been blessed meet lots of them and
Coach a few of them so the mega Stars I
get to work with the Olympians I get to
work with the highest achieving people
in the world they it's not luck and most
of them didn't have unbelievable lucky
family connections what they did is they
hustled they worked they built it and
even if they started a little more
abundant than other people
they outlasted their peers who also
started out abundant because they gave
they worked they struggled through and
we got to keep going
the third thing don't compare yourself
ever in terms of looks appearances
Beauty you know I I know if you're
somebody who opens up those fashion
magazines or their celebrity gossip
magazines you're always looking oh she's
cuter than me oh he's better looking and
then again you have the excuse as soon
as you compare yourself to other people
you have the excuse to never begin you
have the reason to be demoralized I mean
there's if I looked across YouTube and I
started doing my episodes or my videos
or or iTunes or podcasts you know I
would have never begun because you got
all these people out there they're like
they're amazing they look so good they
sound so good and I sucked I couldn't
talk like this before now as you know
all of our videos and every episode I've
ever done has been unscripted no notes I
got nothing I'm looking right at you
there's nothing in front of me I just go
and they're all in one single take
majority of them I think 99 are one take
and that came from practice where for
years and years years years and years
and years I I tried to be able to just
speak extemporaneously without using
notes without using a script I taught
myself to do this and if I'd compared
myself to other people who were so
polished and looking good and every word
was precise I would have never gotten to
where we're at today with literally
hundreds of millions of views and from
our posts to our videos it came because
I didn't worry about the Polish of
looking like everybody else I was just
doing my thing
so what should you compare why should
you be comparing yourself to others for
growth reasons learning reasons I mean
the first reason you should always
compare yourself to others is for
creativity to get ideas not to steal and
not to compare but rather to go oh how
would I do that you know in comparing
yourself to others it brings in
self-awareness to say oh look this is
how I'm distinct this is how I'm
different this is how I could approach
this in a different way if I didn't
research the market I would never know
how I could be different if I didn't
know how it could be different I could
never have a business you cannot build a
business or have a real career or make
any major contribution without
understanding how you're distinct Steve
Jobs knew that when he built the phone
it was different and that thinking
differently is what made him an icon
it's the same for everything that we do
compare so you know what is out there so
you know how you can bring a new
Creative Edge to it second reason to
compare is to compare for vision
because as you get self-awareness and
you understand how you're distinct
sometimes you see someone doing
something amazing and you're like wow I
I got a bigger vision for myself when I
started seeing people posting videos you
know back in 2007 I got a bigger vision
for myself I mean 2007 I saw people
posting longer videos online I thought
wow I never saw myself doing video but
look look at how I'm watching these and
I'm relating with these I got to do some
video and by comparing myself to others
to other people I followed or researcher
read their books and I saw that they had
a podcast I'm like I'm gonna get a
podcast it opened up my vision for the
vehicles the mediums the the ways that I
could serve and give and I want you to
do the same and the last piece the
reason to compare yourself is for growth
there is an amazing amount of talent in
this world and when you see them it
should inspire you to level up it
inspired me to learn how to do video it
inspired me to learn how to speak
extemporaneous and it inspired me to get
over my fears of public speaking and
step on a stage and now it's in front of
thousands and thousands of people to
inspire the world I never I never
thought I could do that but seeing other
people sometimes achieves the remarkable
you get inspired if it's not about if
you can look at someone who's done
something better than you and it
inspires you that means you have
humility and you got a chance
if you look at other people who've
achieved more have more look more feel
good or more amazing than you and you
get bitter or upset that means you're
small and you're destined to smallness
but if you can look at greatness and be
inspired you're on track you're gonna
live an extraordinary quality of life
the kind of life that we call the charge
life in our lives
especially when we're being
reactive
information comes in right we're at an
event we're paying attention to how
people treat us
we're studying something we're trying to
learn something and we're just going
about our regular day information is
coming in how people perceive us the
cause and effective events
things are just happening information
comes into the brain from that point the
information immediately
goes into
interpretation
and what this usually means is
interpretation in the fast reactive
thing is safe unsafe good
bad
like it
don't like it recognize it don't
recognize it
been there done that unfamiliar or
familiar certain uncertain fear safe all
these things start triggering it's
pretty unconscious and it's pretty fast
our biases come into play it's just that
speed spontaneous reactive part of us
and it's that's not always bad sometimes
it can be good
right sometimes it can be good
interpretation could be that event
that's good for me or that events that's
bad for me but usually it's like a snap
judgment think about that most most when
we're talking about an unconscious level
it's like a snap judgment automatic like
you like or don't like her feel safe
don't feel safe it's very fast
then the next level and this is not
always linear of course because your
brain is not left brain right brain kind
of methodology your brain's more of a
spider web of interconnectedness that is
something we still don't understand okay
you can study everything in neuroscience
and you might learn something about this
lobe or that that cortex region but then
only to find out that later on a year
later like well actually it seems like
it's also communicating over here it's a
spider web of unbelievable intelligence
that's happening that and everything can
be millisecond hundreds of milliseconds
of transitions between neural networks
it's unbelievably fast unbelievable
capable so this is just for our
understanding it's not necessarily real
world linear like this but what tends to
happen is as information comes in good
bad we also then move it to
a level of well what does this mean to
me
identity
what does this mean to me what does this
either mean to me or what does this say
about me
how does this apply to me
and if we're not conscious here this is
going to be really Troublesome some of
you discovered that yesterday I bet when
you released a few things sometimes we
have these events in our life that we we
take on and we just assume it meant
something about us and we didn't realize
no that's more of a statement about them
than it is about us
right sometimes when you're hurt or
someone was rude to you it had nothing
to do with you raise your hand you
follow
I had nothing to do with you but if
you're not careful you could say
mean person unsafe means I'm bad child
rude Behavior
uncertain about this I must not belong
terrible situation
I feel bad
I can never be safe again
how many follow how this happens
this is why we have to be very very very
observational of our own thoughts and
feelings because how these things get
labeled can really change our lives
forever well imagine like last night I'm
going on the stage right if I if my
identity says I am a public speaker and
it is important for me to be excellent
at this and then I go on stage and I
bomb
what does that say about me as a person
so we've got about 50 years of work in
Psychology the field of psychology
saying do not tie your efforts to your
identity because that risk of
disappointment or rejection you know if
the task fails you shouldn't take that
as as a defining moment in which you say
I am a failure
right so that's the risk and that's what
you know psychologists tell us to be
wary of except it turns out that high
performers flipped out on its face and
go well actually
um no I do get bothered if it fails I
really get upset about it I am attached
to the process here I I do care if it
turns out well I mean that's why they
obsess about the details that's why they
care about Excellence it's like no one
obsessed about the details or cares
about Excellence unless it means
something to them
and there is a risk the risk is you over
attach
to the process or the outcome
with your identity so that if the
process or outcome goes bad now you feel
bad about yourself as a human and now
you stop your progress
but I also tell people
there's a balance there I actually wish
more people would attach some identity
to what they're doing they wouldn't go
through the motions as much I mean I
think what the world needs less of is
half interested parents
who don't have an identity that says you
know what
I'm gonna be an excellent parent
I think we have a lot of CEOs or
business people or entrepreneurs who
they've never stepped in and said you
know what
I'm a CEO
I own this business I am responsible for
paying the bills I am responsible for
making the money I'm responsible for all
these people's mortgages who work for me
like they I want them to own the
identity of a CEO because most of them
if you ask them about their identity and
their business they're kind of like you
come to find
they're kind of approaching it like
not even hobbyists
it's like if you want to win your
identity has to be tied into that thing
in which you are trying to succeed at
and give to and that takes a lot of guts
to put yourself all in for something but
who's ever contributed something with
tremendous impact without being all into
it I've never seen it so I think the
message of the book you're right I'll
get some Flack of some a lot of
psychologists say don't don't tell
people to tie more of their Identity or
my friends who are Buddhists will say
but attachment is the form of all
suffering but I didn't have you not read
your spiritual attacks I'm like look out
calm down I've hung out with the Dalai
Lama I'm totally cool
but what I'm trying to tell you is even
the Dalai Lama has a connection with
himself as a spiritual leader his
identity is still there that people you
know assume that you know we have to
release ourselves from having the
attachment to something but I'm like I
think we all want to be present and
engaged fully
in the things that we are doing in our
lives
and that's going to require us to say
psychologically you know what I I
am all in this
that's what I'm about it's the Habit is
generate energy okay not necessarily
have energy create energy create energy
and what they do the way we measure that
was kind of academic mental energy which
is tied to your focus and your stamina
and your ability to manage complex tasks
without too much mental stress number
two is emotional energy
which is just the quality or positive
motions
and number three is physical energy
High performers are 40 percent more
likely to work out five times per week
then
the rest of their peers so that means
the top 15 percent most high performing
people in the world tend to work out
five days per week and that workout
could be defined as you know 45 minute
brisk walk or you know hit intensity or
whatever it is but
40 percent more likely that's a huge
finding and what we found is high
performers just have better well-being
and happiness and physical conditioning
than everybody else one stunning finding
was uh CEOs senior Executives and
business owners
they report expending as much energy
as athletes who are competitive now I
can imagine yeah yeah I kind of I was
surprised by that I would have thought
you know athletes would be ten percent
more I mean the emotional and mental
energy we have to the decision making
the conversations the big deals the
stakeness yeah there's a lot of energy
it's a lot that's why I mean if you
really want to achieve your dreams you
have to care for your body yeah your
mind it's why all these things you know
finally resonating in the marketplace
because the science of meditation or
taking a break or you know uh managing
your own energy sleep is everything yeah
um and I think all of that is really
important and we say generate energy
because there's this myth that you know
some people have happiness or they have
it's like
no you generated you don't have
happiness you generally create it yeah
you create it and so the quality of your
energy you have to create like you and I
both I mean if most of our audience knew
our schedules your schedule the last
five days is like how is Lewis even able
to focus right now and how are you able
to get here and do this as well yeah but
it's because we say well this is our
mission show up man yeah there's plenty
of times I gotta imagine you walked on
the field and you were like
I'm exhausted you know I remember when
you like flew down to compete and yeah
yeah I still play with the USA team
handball yeah team and a year ago I flew
down to
I remember I did an interview in Miami
and then flew out from Miami and then
went and just went right into training
camp and then went against Brazil which
is like you know Olympic Olympic
qualifiers and yeah got our asses put
but it was fun you know but I had to
have Clarity yeah she'd show up even
when I was like oh we're gonna lose yeah
like there's zero chance yeah it was
like the worst team in the NBA playing
like the Warriors and we were just like
we had no chance yeah but I had to show
up and give my best and you have to set
all these routines I mean you know the
amount of routines that Tom Brady has in
his life so that he can generate energy
it's unbelievable stuns most people it's
unbelievable and that's just that's
that's what it takes if you want to take
that level if you don't want to be at
that level you don't have to do it yeah
you don't have to do it I mean everybody
can just like well I'm gonna go you know
hit the Cinnabon but it's like it's
pretty good how do you want to feel at
three o'clock yeah if you want to feel
amazing at three o'clock don't end lunch
with a Cinnabon one of the major major
Keys we found the first High performing
habit is seek clarity
and what we found is one of the
practices that high performers do is
they Define the feeling they're after
and so when we had to explain that and
later talk about it in the energy
chapter we had to differentiate between
feelings and emotions and they are
different emotions tend to be they're
the same yeah like we have they're
physical they're almost always automatic
even though in the brain is creating
associations has ought to happen for us
they just kind of emotion comes up yeah
you're watching a movie and you're just
sad and you're like oh my gosh you know
I'm crying you didn't even have the
tissues ready you're just like you know
uh but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make of what
that emotion was and how it sticks and
the meaning we give it to it yeah and
the example I used to you know I like to
give and I don't remember if it's in the
book or not honestly because here's
what's happened this book is 400 pages
it was 1481 when I finished baby you
edited it down yes and it was 1481 good
complete like it was like awesome yes
but I was like that's gonna freak people
out so we're publishing a bunch in
academic journals later and then
stripped it down to 400 pages so it's
more readable and fun and orientable so
I can't remember if this one actually
made it in there but
um the example I like to give is if you
and I go to a haunted house yeah which I
love I love them I love them and they
scare me the crap but if you and I walk
around you know you walk around when the
walls in a haunted house someone jumps
out at you yeah you and I are both gonna
jump yes we are emotionally going to
experience fright immediately it's going
to be there right but I might be freaked
out for the next five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about when we start talking
about energy because emotional energy is
real yes and that is look if at six like
we go to the haunted house at you know 5
PM in the afternoon
if at 9 00 PM now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still feel scared
that's not the haunted houses problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of Terror and fear
and you're still experiencing that
feeling that's a mental job not an
emotional job
so your job is to go wow I'm at my house
I've lived here for 10 years I've never
been threatened this house this is a
safe place I gotta redefine the feeling
I want to experience and I work with one
uh an Olympic sprinter gold medalist
Olympic sprinter as a client and this
person's huge breakthrough
in getting better and going from
literally uh one Olympics before not
meddling at all to now gold I said what
made like what was the thing yeah and
one of the things they said to me was I
learned to define the feeling
and I said what do you mean by that and
he basically said you know if if if
there's a bunch of us at the starting
box and we're all in perfect Poise in
perfect condition the one to bet on is
the one that says this is the way I want
to feel in this race right now I know my
emotions are going crazy like my heart's
beating I can hear everybody I'm waiting
for that shot blast I can see my goal I
know how important this is and all these
um like these their emotions are there
yeah but that person is defining the
feeling going I'm going to feel centered
now
I'm going to get myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is the emotion
of anxiety is there for all Olympic
level competitors all of them but they
Define that feat that emotion as a
feeling that helps give them a
Performance Edge
and I think that's important too you
know Bruce Springsteen says if he's ever
backstage and doesn't feel like nerves
he's going to hang it up yeah
but that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently it's so simple like when you
get the life is really short and you
felt that before but either by you were
threatened or you've had someone near
dear near and dear die but when you have
that real Essence in you that says life
is short have reverence for it live it
that's a really big thing I got that at
19 and I learned specifically that if we
have a moment of cognition before the
end of our life we tend to ask questions
to evaluate if we're happy
so if I have any impact in the world
it's going to come from that experience
where
I learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine what the questions you're
going to ask at the end of your life are
going to be
find out those questions what will you
ask at the end of your life to evaluate
your life
so that you would know if you were happy
with your life like figure out those
questions
and then live each day
intentionally so you're happy with the
answers at the end
for me the answer is the questions I had
were did I live
which I hadn't I'd been living my life
I've been thinking about taking my life
that I love
no my heart was broken
and I put up all these walls to keep out
other people and I always say you know
sometimes the walls we put up to keep
out the bad guys prevent the good guys
from getting in and suddenly in our own
self-protection we block out the very
thing we want which is connection
and I learned that I would ask did I
matter
you know 22 years ago
on a dark Caribbean night I'm standing
on the crumpled hood of a car
Bleeding Out
my friend
when I just wrecked a car he's screaming
at top of his lungs he's bleeding we
know if we're gonna live and I'm
standing on this car
looking down all this blood and I'm in
Terror
and I just remember looking down the
hood and just thinking
did I even matter
you know
and I hated the answer at that time in
life
because a 19 year old kid I didn't know
about impact Theory
for real I didn't know to think about
that you some you know young kids
sometimes they don't know to think about
that I didn't know to think about
Legacy meaning
did I matter I didn't think I did
but the good news is I'm a good learner
and I felt like I got a second chance
from God that night and I learned that
it was really important for me to figure
out how do I live and how do I love and
how do I matter in such a way that if I
face my death again I'll know
I've earned the second chance
and so what I want to tell people and
the impact I want is I just want people
to know know your questions Man live
intentionally and earn the life that
you've been given because This Moment's
a blessing so earn this moment and live
intentionally dude if you're angry all
the time you gotta change how you look
at the world yes there's a lot in the
news that can piss you off yes there's a
lot going on that causes outrage all day
long on Twitter or social media
somewhere but if that's your sole Focus
no wonder you're upset all the time lots
of people are angry right now because of
the news or something chaotic or
terrible or something they don't agree
with is happening in the world but
that's not new there's always chaos
there's always turmoil there's always
bad things happen in the world but if
that's your focus no wonder you're
having that anxiety and that frustration
and that anger all the time you got to
change both your focus and how you're
reacting to things when you do see it so
first let's work on your focus you know
our as much as you're angry all the time
are you also noticing the beauty of this
world I mean the odds that you're even
alive and having your breath is
something to connect to every single
morning to have reverence for your life
in the morning to wake up in one of my
late mentors was Wayne Dyer an amazing
amazing teacher and he always talked
about how he woke up he rolled over he
put his feet on the ground and he said
thank you
thank you thank you he was grateful for
his day and he began that way and I
think so many people right now they kind
of roll up in bed and they're like and
they grab their freaking phone and they
start going through the news on social
media and what are they queuing
immediately I'm cueing stress chaos
turmoil clickables you know it's like
clickbait click clickbait no wonder
you're frustrated you're activating your
brain immediately right off the
beginning of the day in all the turmoil
of the world put the dang phone down get
up and think about what you're grateful
for about what you want to achieve and
give and serve and create that day about
who needs you to be on your A-game that
day so you can focus on that instead of
like this in bed that will change how
you start your day and then listen a lot
of people who are angry all the time
they're also in Outrage all the time
because they're focusing on the problem
all the time and they're bemoaning the
problem they're calling out the problem
complaining about the problem judging
criticizing getting upset all the time a
ton of people who stay in anger all the
time are failing to be solution based
that's what they're doing right they're
just anger anger problem problem outrage
outrage outrage but listen when you
become a solution-based person you say
okay I actually want to do something
about this problem and you start taking
positive steps to at least address it or
to participate suddenly that anger goes
into a new fire and that fire is called
enthusiasm it is easy to switch anger
into enthusiasm when you become solution
based as a mindset when you say okay I
don't like this let me do something let
me let me call somebody let me take this
action let me write that letter let me
send that email let me get my friends
together let's go protest let's go get
involved let's participate because
participation turns anger often into
enthusiasm and so if you're just stewing
on the things you don't like of course
it's going to be a negative energy but
if you start stewing on the things that
you can do you find personal power you
find enthusiasm you find Social
contribution ultimately you find
Community because one reason it's so
easy to be angry is when you're alone
you're at home you're sort of thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about all the negative things and you
don't have an outlet of other human
beings to discuss with especially
solution-oriented people or people with
ideas and dreams and Ambitions people
who are doing stuff with their life
because listen when you're on a path of
purpose you ain't got time for drama
I don't have time for a ton of anger in
my life because I'm too busy making
positive changes that's where we want to
get you we want to shift your attention
and focus in the morning we want to
start making you more solution based and
get your community of people around who
are ambitious and driven to change and
to make positive change happen when we
do that the anger starts going away and
if you can't get over the anger yourself
then don't be shy about asking for help
you know a lot of people they don't have
anybody to talk to so I'm like get a
therapist man get in a group man talk
with some people go to a seminar getting
a new sort of environment you want to
get rid of the anger go volunteer get
around other people who are making
positive impacts that community that
shift changes your life you don't have
to be angry anymore and the last part
about that is Letting Go
you got to let go of those things that
upset you three years ago five years ago
10 years ago if you're an adult and
you're still angry and pissed of things
that happen to you and high School you
need a therapist and I say that with all
sincerity and all respect if you're
having mental thoughts that are coming
from a place that are literally based 5
10 20 years ago that you just didn't
deal with yet you need help dealing with
it and you need to get yourself a
meditation practice or a therapist or in
some kind of way that you're on a
consistent basis letting things go
here's what I do every Sunday I go okay
what was I pissed about this last week
what really bothered me okay I gotta let
that go
because you can't keep charging into the
next week angry from last week you got
to let it go you gotta find a clean
slate for yourself so that your your
soul can expand and can be positive and
can be ambitious and motivated and
serving the next week because listen
anger after anger after anger hatred
after hatred after hatred criticism
after criticism after criticism
rejection after rejection after
rejection outrage after outrage after
outrage it weighs you down
so you've got to change how much of that
you're taking in and you've got to make
sure every single week you're doing some
kind of like mental detox to let that
stuff go and instead of cultivating the
anger cultivate the Gratitude cultivate
the enthusiasm and you can change your
life because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want another amazing
Brendan burchard video check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there